ich würde schon behaupten dass das die
leckerste Schokoladencreme ist die ich
bisher gegessen habe
[Musik]
wir sind zurück von der Sommerpause und
glücklicher denn je heute gibt es eine
Geburtstagstorte mit hoffentlich gleich
fünf brennenden Kerzen
ich hoffe euch geht's gut herzlich
Willkommen zu Sallys Welt in Sallys Welt
herzlich willkommen instally's Welt
heute gibt es diese Geburtstagstorte die
habe ich letztes Jahr für meine Freundin
Anna zubereitet Anna Kamera
und zwar hat er die Anna im Dezember
Geburtstag und wir haben eine richtig
schöne Geburtstagsüberraschung für Sie
vorbereitet
Last Minute fällt mir ein ich habe keine
Geburtstagstorte ich habe vergessen die
Torte zu backen ich habe gepackt ich
habe Luftballons ich habe dies ich habe
jede ich habe die Torte vergessen und
habe ich gedacht ich mache schnelle Last
Minute Torte und das ist seht ihr lasst
mir eine Torte ihr könnt diese Torte in
innerhalb von
45 Minuten zubereiten wenn ihr noch ein
bisschen schummelt so ein bisschen
Gefrierfach und Kühlschrank
zweckentfremdet klappt es mit 45 Minuten
ansonsten braucht ihr eine Stunde oder
ein bisschen länger aber dann habt ihr
eine hohe Torte die wirklich toll
aussieht Topf schmeckt schokoladig ist
ihr könnt diese goldenen Kerzen drauf
dekorieren und ihr habt einfach ein
Highlight für jeden Geburtstag ich würde
sagen wir gar keine Zeit sondern starten
direkt nämlich mit den Böden und dafür
zeige ich euch kurz die Zutaten dafür
nehme ich 250 Gramm Butter 250 Gramm
Zucker etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt 250
Gramm Flüssigkeit eurer Wahl drei Eier
150 Gramm Joghurt 250 Gramm Mehl mit
Backpulver oder nimmt mein backmehl und
100 Gramm Kakao ihr nehmt jetzt zuerst
die Eier die kommen in die Rührschüssel
und das ganze ist eine wirklich schnelle
Torte alles klappt ganz schnell jetzt
gleich eier und Zucker rein etwas Salz
und Vanilleextrakt und dann könnte die
Zutaten verrühren und in der
Zwischenzeit die Butter schmelzen
[Musik]
die Zwischenzeit habe ich jetzt genutzt
und meine vier Backrahmen eingeschlagen
bzw backringe ich nehme jetzt hier vier
backringe mit 16 cm Durchmesser da wird
die Torte schön hoch wenn ihr aber wollt
dass sie vom Durchmesser her größer wird
könnte natürlich auch größere Ringe
nehmen hier ist halt der Vorteil ich
kann vier Böden gleichzeitig backen es
passt alles perfekt aufs Backblech und
dann bin ich auch echt schnell fertig
jetzt gebe ich hier die Flüssigkeiten
rein und da könnt ihr jetzt alles nehmen
Kaffee ihr könnt Fanta oder Limonaden
verwenden ihr könnt Buttermilch nehmen
alles was ihr gerade da habt oder was
eben die Torte den bestimmten Geschmack
den besonderen Geschmack geben sollen
alle Flüssigkeiten rein auch die Butter
hier könnt ihr auch gerne Öl verwenden
dann Joghurt dazu und kurz verrühren und
dann die trockenen Zutaten nur noch kurz
einrühren und dann ist der Teig schon
fertig
[Musik]
dann hier direkt einfüllen verstreichen
und im vorgeheizten Ofen backen und die
Backzeit nutze ich dann um schon mal die
Creme zuzubereiten und dann seid ihr
wirklich ganz schnell fertig mit der
Torte tschüss
[Musik]
für die Creme verwende ich 200g Sahne
200 g Zartbitterschokolade 250 Gramm
weiche Butter 60g Puderzucker 250g
Frischkäse 60 Gramm Kakao und etwas
Tonka Paste wenn ihr möchtet das ist so
eine Creme die ich sehr gerne herstelle
weil sie schnell geht und jedem schmeckt
und vor allem auch sehr stabil ist also
selbst wenn ihr die Torte transportiert
ich habe zum Beispiel meine
Geburtstagstorte die ich gemacht habe
über 300 Kilometer transportiert und es
ist nichts passiert ist einfach eine
Creme die ihr wirklich ganz toll
zubereiten könnt und die ist einfach
perfekt dafür stellt ihr nämlich erstmal
eine Garage das heißt die Sahne
aufkochen den Herd ausschalten und die
Schokolade einrühren
wenn ihr das in so einer großen
emailschüssel macht habt ihr den Vorteil
weil im Mai einfach ein sehr Temperatur
leitfähiges Material ist es wird schnell
heiß aber wenn ich es dann zum Abkühlen
bringen möchte wird es auch wieder
schnell kalt und so spare ich eben dann
auch Zeit im Alltag
[Musik]
jetzt schön einrühren bis alles
geschmolzen ist
[Musik]
wenn sich dann alles gut verbunden hat
nehmt ihr die Creme deckt sie ab und
stellt sie entweder auf eine kalte
Platte also jetzt wie bei mir auf meiner
Arbeitsplatte die ist immer schön kalt
oder ihr könnt sie auch auf akkupads zum
Beispiel Stellen aus dem Kühlschrank ich
habe es auch schon ab und zu so gemacht
dass ich sie im Kühlschrank gestellt
habe aber das darf man natürlich nicht
weil man sich da die Elektrogeräte
kaputt macht also das sollte man immer
vermeiden aber wenn der Kühlpads im
Kühlschrank habt einfach drunter legen
und dann wird die richtig schnell kalt
und die stelle ich jetzt nämlich zur
Seite und kann in der Zwischenzeit die
Butter mit dem Puderzucker schön cremig
verrühren
[Musik]
schauen wir in der Zwischenzeit mal
direkt hier nach dem Bögen
20 Sekunden hätten sie noch
oder
perfekt
die Böden sind gebacken und damit sie
schnell abkühlen wirklich sofort vom
heißen Blech runter nehmen
und am besten auf abkühlgitter setzen
dabei kommen sie nämlich von unten auch
Luft und kühlen eben schön ab ohne dass
sie schwitzen das ist immer ganz wichtig
und auch hier wenn ihr einen Platz habt
einfach auf die kalte Terrasse stellen
auf eine kalte Platte oder nach dem
etwas Herunterkühlen ab in den
Kühlschrank
er löst sich sogar von alleine guck dir
das mal an
hier ist jetzt die Butter schön weiß
cremig da gebe ich etwas Tonka Paste
dazu wenn ihr möchtet ihr könnt aber
auch gerne im Likör dazugeben oder
andere Geschmäcker die euch ganz gut
schmecken dann Frischkäse rein Kakao
rein und die abgekühlte Ganache und dann
schön cremig rühren das war's schon
[Musik]
wird echt behaupten
ohne dass ich jetzt schon überall auf
der Welt war und noch nicht alles
gesehen habe von der Welt aber ich würde
schon behaupten dass das die leckerste
Schokoladencreme ist die ich bisher
gegessen habe
vielleicht gibt es noch eine bessere auf
der Welt aber die ist schon sehr gut
ist fertig das heißt ich habe meine
Böden fertig die kühlen gerade die Creme
ist fertig und wie gesagt unter uns wenn
es mal richtig schnell gehen muss dann
die Böden kurz einfrieren dann geht's
auch schnell und dann könnt ihr die
Torte wenn ihr sagt schokolade ist gut
aber ihr wollt so ein bisschen Frucht
könnt ihr entweder gleich eine Marmelade
verwenden oder ein bärenpüree und bei
mir ist es immer so wenn ich Beeren
übrig habe im Kühlschrank und ich weiß
gerade nicht was ich damit anfangen soll
oder ich habe während Mix oder Himbeeren
Erdbeeren irgendwas übrig dann koche ich
sie immer ganz gerne ein und friere sie
hier in so Eiswürfeln in so
eiswürfelbehältern ein dann habe ich
immer Wasser Vorrat und kann eben
entscheiden ob ich jetzt eine Marmelade
nehmen oder so ein Bären Mix und das
hier ist einfach so ohne Zucker
praktisch eingefroren
aufgetaut und dann kann ich das hier
erwärmen und die Torten würden nämlich
damit bestreichen und habe so ein
bisschen noch Fruchtanteil mit dabei
ohne zu viel süßer
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles schön kalt ich muss
sagen ich habe sie wenn es also noch
lauwarm waren kurz in Gefrierschrank das
sind die innerhalb von fünf Minuten
ready und jetzt könnt ihr die Torte
schön Schichten
also nehmt ihr euch eine Tortenplatte
erster Boden drauf dann könnt ihr dann
ein bisschen Creme drauf streichen wenn
ihr wollt wenn ihr keine fruchtige Torte
wollt lasst einfach weg
und jetzt die Schokoladencreme
und die streiche einfach so ein bisschen
auf aber nicht ganz bis zum Rand denn
die anderen Böden die drücken die Creme
so ein bisschen noch raus
[Musik]
und jetzt die letzte Schicht und das
gute ist wenn die Tortenböden schon so
ein bisschen gefroren sind dann wird ja
auch die Creme richtig schön fest und
dann läuft euch die Torte auch nicht
auseinander das heißt ihr könnt sie dann
direkt auf einmal schön stapeln und die
Butter darin wird schön fest
falls euch die Torte aber zu weich ist
dann stellt sie ruhig auch zwischendurch
mal in den Kühlschrank und ich finde es
ist einfach jetzt so eine schöne naked
Torte die oben drauf auch schön wellig
mit richtig viel Creme dekoriert wird
und dann mit Gold aus dekoriert wird ich
nehme jetzt goldene Kerzen dann nehme
ich noch so ein paar Rocher Kugeln
[Musik]
die Rocher Kugeln könnt ihr dann noch
mit Goldpulver ein bisschen ummanteln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist sie fertig die blitzschnelle
Schokoladen Geburtstagstorte und dann
nehmt ihr euch ein Feuerzeug oder einen
Bunsenbrenner wie ich immer weil ich den
Feuerzeug habe und serviert sie
fertig ist die Schokoladentorte die
blitzschnell geht was für
Schokoladenliebhaber ist und ich finde
wenn man sie schön aus dekoriert mit
etwas Gold auch richtig edel aussieht
ich würde sagen ich suche mir jetzt hier
ein Geburtstagskind und dann probieren
wir die Torte
[Musik]
Youtube
Geburtstagstorte Tolga willst du sie
probieren
[Musik]
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy Birthday Mikrofon so
ich bin Ausschnitt können Sie jetzt
benutzen und den Ausschnitt dieses happy
Birthday von Tolga und Sally könnte
jetzt so Bildschirmaufnahme machen und
dann alle eure Freunde senden
happy birthday to you happy Birthday
ja ja
habe es noch nie gehört
ja okay wir wünschen uns was posten aus
und dann schreiben wir an
[Musik]
weil wenn man sowas laut ausspricht dann
kommt es nicht in der Füllung deswegen
hast gesprochen
[Musik]
aber ich kann mir schon denken was du
dir wünschst
[Musik]
oh Gott mach schnell den Teller so
aufrecht
da wow saftig
[Musik]
Schokoladenliebhaber das ist genau was
für euch
[Musik]
und in der fruchtcreme
ich liebe Tonka über alles
boah ist die lecker und zur zart
ich sag euch mal was gerade eben musste
ich ihn dazu motivieren zu probieren und
jetzt denkt dass ich so oh gott sei Dank
das Ding ist wir essen hier so viel
Kuchen und in der Mittagspause hatten
wir erst und dann habe ich gedacht dass
wir jetzt zu viel aber das Spiel
ich weiß und ich
[Musik]
was ein Staat nach der Sommerpause
und selbst wenn kein Geburtstag ansteht
backt diese Torte nach die ist der
Hammer stimmt muss ja kein Geburtstag
sein
[Musik]
also schaut gerne in meiner App vorbei
da gibt es Tortenrezepte aber auch
natürlich gesunde Rezepte ja das muss
nicht übertreiben hier mit den Kalorien
schaut gerne vorbei und schreibt mir mal
ob ihr auch Schokoladenliebhaber seid
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
fürs ganze Thema aber ich glaube die
reicht dir ne
ich würde jetzt mitnehmen ich bin heute
Abend auch noch geburtstag
wir laufen immer so original bis hierher
und bleiben immer stehen als würden wir
immer aus der Küche laufen irgendwohin
kurzer real Talk wenn wir hier aus der
Küche laufen das muss ich euch jetzt
erzählen ich weiß ihr könnt sich
wahrscheinlich nicht vorstellen aber wir
laufen dann wieder zurück setzen die
Torte ab verpacken sie und essen sie im
Team denn es steht noch ein Rezept Dreh
an und vielleicht noch ein Rezept Dreh
aber irgendwann haben wir uns angewöhnt
aus der Küche zu laufen
so also pack mal die Weg jetzt geht es
weiter damit das nächste mittwochsrezept
kommen kann
[Musik]